Westworld people love the show
absolutely love the show I love the show
I don't for the life of me understand
how they they make a season of this show
it looks like I mean it's the most
beautiful complex you know richly
realized universe you can imagine it's
an unbelievable achievement there's a
lot of gore on the set
yes does that bother you at all yes
because there's I mean there's
characters because there's a lot of
synthetic people there getting their
heads blown off left and right and it
looks quite realistic yes well I mean
the special effects stuff is is
beautiful and the you know the magic of
that show is they don't use a lot of
green-screen they don't do a lot of
right ah you know you know after visual
effects it's all in camera tools
you know prosthetics and yeah beautiful
makeup but I had I had a crazy moment I
was like ah you know don't take my kids
to to work that'll be great
what am i doing it's like a horror movie
it's just shattered bodies up bodies
everywhere with blown out chest laughing
heads and I know you I mean there's
there's it's great because it helps you
as an actor this is very little acting
required when you actually have to soar
through you know a prosthetic hair that
has it feels like what I imagined it
would be really awesome person I mean
when blood comes out and keep going like
on yeah so like they just get some
mannequins from the store and put them
there and then add it all later this is
really an upsetting experience not even
probably scarred mentally by this whole
experience I mean I would have been if I
hadn't grown up with your tragic
childhood comes back yeah we have a clip
here from Westworld anything you can
tell us about this clip uh I think this
is just after our Stubbs is going to
check the surf I think and he finds
Bernard on the beach and he walks up and
says some things
I really I didn't ask you to cut out the
clip I've never heard anyone do that
before then I say this that he says that
I really feel no reason to show the clip
I know the gist of it but let's take a
look at this clip from grass world
hey hey get up get your hands where I
can see them right
I'm gonna shoot the boss
but you're pretty out of sorts right now
yeah
let's get you back to base still
espresso gonna want to talk to you
is short at Zuma yeah there is out there
that's a notice that my face is really
dirty yeah and it's because the first
week of shooting we're shooting in those
ATVs and we're in this really really
dusty area and it was like someone was
just pouring a bucket of dust on your
face and I got out of the ATV and
they're like hey so why is that dusty
I'm like you can't see yeah I've been
eating this Gnostic toxic dust for wait
a minute why don't you have makeup
people that wipe the dust off your face
no but the dust is on marrinson camera
and so they have to put the dust on for
the rest of the season Oh
[Applause]
you